Community Brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
Findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this next segment believe that customer
service means making your vehicle buying
experience enjoyable and they're also
committed to providing training and
employment in southern Nevada with their
fit vocational training and here to tell
us more is CFO of Findlay automotive
group Tyler quarter and auto technician
from Findlay Chevrolet Thomas Whitney
welcome you guys thank you it's great to
be here Tyler it's so great to see you
we all know that the Findlay automotive
group really serves their customers here
but you also provide jobs for people
here in southern Nevada with this with
this program tell us a little bit about
it so uh so I serve on the board of the
foundation for independent tomorrow or
fit and we have it's a vocational
training program to try to get people
off of Public Assistance or get them to
a point where they're self-sufficient
can provide for their family
of course I also have Finley Auto Group
and we have a need for automotive
technicians so a couple years ago we
teamed up and created an automotive
technician vocational training program
and we've been we've run I think four or
five classes through the program now
it's a 16-week program and every one of
the graduates of the program so far
we've been able to hire them at Findlay
automotive dealerships and so it's
really exciting for us because it's
filling a need for us it's also giving
people good jobs Thomas
graduated from our second class and he
now works for us at Finley Finley
Chevrolet Thomas how has it been for you
being how is the program itself and how
has it been for you now working there
and being part of the Finley Automotive
Group the program itself has just been
an amazing experience an amazing
opportunity to get your foot right in
the door in the automotive industry and
I'm lucky enough to be a part of the
Chevy group and I love it it's been a
great day and I learned something new
every day let's hope
although we're interested in maybe
becoming a part of this and and joining
the next class can they do that yeah we
have classes on every 16 weeks we run
another class and uh so through the uh
the foundation for independent tomorrow
but it's called our standards of
excellence program so you can go to
standards of excellence's website it's
got all the information there there's a
place to call or apply online and get
all the information you need to join the
program and so and we have scholarship
money available it's an awesome program
and Automotive technician is a needed
skill so there are jobs available at the
end of the program that's probably the
biggest key is we're putting people to
work in a position that pays good pays
good money yeah you have to be highly
intelligent to be able to do what you do
Thomas what is the best part of your job
what do you love about it honestly the
people there the community it really is
a welcoming Community you walk in every
day and you're happy to be there you
know and there's never been a time where
I ask a question I feel discouraged
about asking that question so that's
just the Finley Automotive way it really
is thank you guys so much for telling us
about that program for for doing what
you do and we can always depend on you
to contribute to this community thank
you guys so much we are going to send it
over to you Kendall